you've spent a lot of time studying
history and writing about current events
at the moment how would you rate your
predictive ability given the current
state of the world were the things that
you foresaw coming or things that you've
been particularly surprised
by um well nobody gets to predict with
100% accuracy anything because among
other things all the time things happen
that you could never have seen coming I
could never have seen coid coming I just
didn't um so when anyone sort of boasts
about their predictive capabilities I
always think you have to do it with a
certain amount of humility
because I mean things happen all the
time you couldn't see you can only see
Round the Bend of the road you're coming
to you can't see around the corner um
yeah I mean some things I've written
about for years particularly in my book
The Strange death of Europe that came
out in 2017 which I think are sadly uh
coming to fruition and I say sadly
because it people think that if you've
predicted something and got it right you
would feel any pleasure and that would
only be if the thing you were predicting
was something you looked forward to and
what I was predicting was somebody I was
something I was dreading and
um that was the transformation of our
country of birth uh and many other
countries in the west due to demographic
change and I mean every day now pretty
much somebody says to me gosh I used to
think what you were saying and the
strange death of Europe was a bit out
there and now I realize you were right
but it gives me no pleasure for them to
say that cuz I always sort of think well
if you'd have agreed back then some
things might not have happened but so
but you know as um Mark Stein said you
know demographics is Destiny so uh it's
one of the things you can predict with
the most ease yeah did you have Victoria
Secrets plan to bring sexy back on your
2023 bingo card why are Victoria Secrets
bringing sexy bag after experimenting
with 300b mannequins plus-sized models
disabled models trans models a male
model and a 38-year-old football player
Victoria Secrets have made the
controversial decision to switch
strategy and start using hot women to
model their underwear again it makes
commercial sense to my mind um yeah it
is quite E I'm always amazed that
advertising Executives find it complex
this stuff I mean all you need to do is
stick sexy guys on stuff and stick sexy
girls on stuff and you can sell
merchandise which pretty much writes
itself um yeah I'm I'm I'm not
particularly surprised that if you stick
lizo in a bikini it's not as appealing
as a bit of sales merchandise but you
know live and learn I suppose lizen
learn Liz and learn uh one of my friends
owns a very big clothing company and for
a while they
tried plus-sized models yeah uh mostly
for women there's not much of a body
positivity movement for men no not like
a beer gut movement the skinny fat
Revolution uh and uh he said we've split
tested this into Oblivion Big Girls
Don't sell clothes so when you see that
when you see a company you know and
summers are making double plus-sized
dildos or whatever uh the the company is
actively hurting the top line and bottom
line to be able to send the right
message and that's all well and good up
until some shareholder meeting where
some 7sy old guy looks at the far right
column of an Excel sheet and
goes what the [__] this yes and they
go no no you don't understand it's this
really cool New Movement uh it's very
Progressive and he goes I don't care
right I want more money than we had last
year and this is less money than we had
last year yeah yeah they um well I mean
I suppose it all starts off from a good
place like some or many things but uh
look if
you you might agree that you know it's
not a good thing to sell anorexic
looking models to young women that's
yeah okay let's all agree on that but
you can you can stop somewhere before
morbidly obese you know that's where the
whole thing goes wrong with body
positivity thing plus there's a place
where the body positivity shouldn't
occur it should be I mean if somebody is
so morbidly obese that they're at
significant risk of heart failure you
shouldn't celebrate them you should say
hang on a minute steady on the donuts
but they don't say that they just do
they they they they they run all the way
I wish you could just have sort of
healthy looking women uh on the ads and
and just draw the line there but as as
ever they they sort of don't know where
the line is until they you say something
wrenches them back and I think wrenches
them back is normally as you say the
bottom line yeah I uh I've been thinking
about this sort of performative empathy
point for a while got this idea I need
to Mee it better but I think something
like um short-term empathy or the
shallow Pond of empathy I've been
thinking
about what is most popular in culture at
the moment is something that optimizes
for its immediacy to signal that you are
a good guy or good girl right even if
that's at the expense of the ultimate
outcome for the person so let's say
you're able to do something giving the
child ice cream it may be What It Wants
right now it may be bad for it long term
but if you're the ice cream promoter for
the young children you will be seen as a
good person uh and if you're the person
who's saying hang on a second yeah
that's not what you want longterm maybe
responsibility in Peterson language
maybe not casual sex in Louise Perry
language maybe you know not as much food
as you want in body positivity language
uh you're seen
as bigoted or judgmental or that's
because there's no countervailing force
in the culture the the the unlimited
empathy people have run a long way very
fast because as you say there's a
short-term gain to be seen to be being
empathetic you know let's celebrate
yourself um but ordinarily you would
have some other counter force in the
society and different for different
forces have provided that in history
including the church but if there is no
counterforce to say for instance you
know uh long long-term gratification
better than short-term or you know
whatever don't then then yeah and and
and then that's a sort of unappealing
position in our society now there's
there's PL of room for people to be in
that space but it's still you're still
on the defensive you know we still live
in in a society where effectively to own
an ice cream truck you know in the sort
of language of a child would seem to be
a great thing because they have the
short-term thing um yeah not many people
want that role it's sort of uncool in
some way it might become cool at some
point in the future when more people
realize that the short-term
gratification thing was leading to
diabetes or whatever but it's the same
as one one of the justifications I think
for why people aren't having children
that upfront children you just see a
very very large cost on all of the joy
and and stuff well see The Economist put
it as the the child tax the amount of
money you have less if you have a child
very weird way round to look at the
future of the species isn't it if only I
died with more money in my bank
account life of
regret I death of regret perhaps yeah
well you know it's kind of the uh as
well the the Mexican fisherman story are
you familiar with that the parable of
the Mexican fisherman no I don't think I
am this is cool you'll like this
so an American businessman goes on
holiday to Mexico and while he's there
it's a true story it's a parable right
okay got it [__]
hell he goes on holiday he gets taken
out uh fishing by a local Mexican and he
asks the Mexican how he spends his time
the Mexican says I fish a little on the
morning I catch enough for my family we
go back we cook we laugh around the fire
and I spend time with my children and
the American businessman goes that's
stupid here's a better idea what you
should do is actually spend most of your
day fishing and then with the Surplus
fish you could sell them at the market
and the Mexican Fishman says why would I
do that so well once you've got the
additional money you could start to
employ some of your friends and they
could come out fishing with you too and
you could catch more fish which you
could sell at the market for more money
he said why would I do that he says well
once you've done that you would be able
to incorporate in America and you would
maybe be able to start a canning Factory
so that you could own the entire
production process and you could then
sell the company for a lot of money said
why would I do that he said because once
you'd done that you'd be able to fish a
little on a morning and then go back and
spend time with your children around the
fire very good and I often think about
that as a much more direct route to to
happiness you know yeah um well that's
that's the classic thing that you the
place you uh end up is the place you
started from but yes um there are lots
of reasons why people aren't having
children um and a lot of them are simple
economic things I mean all of the
Western countries that have terrible
replacement birth rate figures are
because of very easy things to solve
like cost of housing and things like
that it's it's not hard to build
affordable housing we just proved to be
incapable of doing so so young people
wanting to wanting to both get on the
property ladder and have a and start a
family think they have to do either or
and they're not entirely wrong but
that's something that governments could
have sorted out and none of them do
they're so hopeless at it and they have
been for years under consecutive
government they never build enough
housing so young people don't see a
future don't feel hopeless and then
don't have kids and then everyone
wonders why there's a demographic
crisis intergenerational competition
theory is something I learned about a
couple of weeks ago you familiar with
this yeah yeah I didn't know about it
before but it makes complete sense you
know there was always this talk of
Millennials are the first generation to
have done worse than their parents and
it seems well they're not the first
first in a little while yes in two
generations yeah long um and it seems
like Millennials actually probably just
about managed to get over on average uh
but jenz materially yeah difficulty in
getting in the property ladder the most
common living arrangement for men under
35 is still at home with their parents
awful um and uh yeah you know it it
bakes in this sort
of
intergenerational competitive
and a dissatisfaction when you look at
where your parents were and this sure
you know felt sense that your parents
got advantages that you never did which
is usually not true I mean they didn't
suffer inflation at the same rates but
they suffered very high taxation the
postwar period um we haven't had
taxation as the levels it was at in the
1960s and70s for instance in the UK um
uh was a time when people were top rate
taxpayers were paying 99% tax a friend
who once in that period paid over 100% %
tax one year for reasons he can possible
it'll be back tax and that sort of thing
so I mean we there's a tendency
particularly among uh Millennials and
after to think that their parents had it
very easy and my experience of people
from that generation the boomer
generation it didn't feel easy at the
time and yeah there were certain things
getting on the property housing ladder
was a little bit easier than it is or
significantly easier once you have what
is it five times average earnings being
you know the
inadequate to to get to the average
property price you see the a split go
on but you you always have to factor I
like if you say you know the millennial
the first ones or gen Z were the first
ones in said whoever to have a better
standard of living you have to bake in
things like oh yeah but they had a World
War you
know so that's quite a big PS well
that's a big footnote um so yeah
everyone everyone has their challenges I
just don't see why why you want you've
identified them know the way out of them
you don't do them
but I was talking to mutual friend Eric
Weinstein about this I also spoke to Sam
about this I've spoken to a bunch of
people why in your opinion do you
think everybody struggles to agree on
the truth
now oh that's quite straightforward We
can't agree on what's
happened so uh broadly speaking an event
happens now and some people believe it
has happened and other people think it
hasn't um I mean we've been through a
number of deranging years since we first
spoke in which for instance you know as
I say there's been a global pandemic
which some people believe was something
which killed millions and millions of
people in their own country and think
they were just about saved from dying
themselves and other people think it was
a fake and other people think we just
massively overreacted and other people
think uh it was all planned and
um nobody agrees what happened
uh that's just to take one example in
America you have obviously the fact that
that nobody agrees who won an election
that's a problem and so you just have
basic things nobody can agree on it just
happened I always say in America you
know it' be nice if we could just agree
that one thing that's just happened
happened but then nobody wants to and
says You must be a WF shill if you if
you if you believe that so I think it is
the problem and then obviously
underneath that is just the problem the
fact that uh the treadmill of social
media has totally changed the way which
we communicate the way in which we learn
things absorb things and we don't know
what the consequences of that are we're
so early into it
um and it seems to me that among other
things it's allowed people to have their
own version of recent events recent
history past few days and so when you
sit down to talk to somebody you can
fairly swiftly work out whether they're
somebody who's open to the idea of
things that happened having happened or
whether or not they will fight you all
the way and um that just makes
everything much harder than it used to
be and that isn't to sort of
particularly Pine for the era of a mono
narrative if that if that era ever
particularly existed and and you read
history not clear that it did um but
it's just m massively worse and news is
coming at us at such a pace these days
that it's just like you know every day
feels like you know a months worth of
news in the past things just fly by you
so fast that you don't even have time to
absorb it before it's happened um so I
think that's part of the reason um and
in any case the whole concept of Truth
as being a desirable thing in the
society seems to have eroded from both
the right and the left and how
um well uh Truth for instance used to be
the basis for
University uh education and the basis of
University inquiry that you sought the
truth wherever it led you that was the
point of Academia for instance uh
politics was different politics was
always about having to find a way around
truth and deal with it and address
inconvenience yeah address it where you
could but you know get round it if it
was too awkward but inquiry used to be
about seeking truth and they' been like
that for couple of thousand years or
more since the Greeks certainly and then
it changed at some point relatively
recently and um truth is now not a
desirable thing because truth hurts
people and um it can be mean so it's not
only that people have different opinions
on things they don't agree that the
thing we used to agree on is worth they
have different facts as well well they
have different facts but they don't
agree that the I mean they don't agree
that you should just follow truth
wherever it takes you um because other
things are prioritized over truth I
still prioritize truth over all things
if I can and try to and uh I think
that's the interesting thing about the
world is finding out what in it is true
and what is not but other people don't
seem to have that same um appetite
anymore and uh would
rather live in lies which I think is
very dangerous for an individual and
very dangerous for
society um in fact it's it's it's
dangerous for an individual and lethal
in a society I'd say
yeah it's interesting to think about the
motivations that people have for
not
believing something which is already on
an un shaky Foundation of We can't agree
on the thing that we're not believing
about and uh ginda one of my friends has
this idea that
uh if no amount of evidence would
dissuade someone of what they believe
then they don't have a rational belief
they have a religious ideology yeah yeah
that's Jonathan Swift uh beautifully put
it as if you can't reason somebody out
of a position they weren't reasoned
into of course I you're dealing with
Dogma with many people today it's just
they don't know which Faith they belong
to but it's Dogma for sure I just
they're not very interested in their
views uh because I think they can't
defend them and if you can't defend your
views I'm not very interested in them
because I don't find them
persuasive I asked Sam this about
whether or
not it obviously whatever 10 15 years
ago he was a big part of the new atheist
movement and I guess you were
tangentially on I was a little bit of a
whipper snapper I was a whipper snapper
new aist you're an Orbiter it's referred
to I was I was a short
trousers uh new atheist okay um but you
know your book uh The Madness of crowds
talks about the collapse of grand
narratives you one of the biggest
collapses of grand narratives was
religion so I asked Sam whether or not
looking back he believed that his
deconstruction of religion was on
balance a net good or a net uh
negative what did he say he he managed
to evade being too committal either way
uh I think but what do you think what's
your opin well I think it's like a lot
of things that you
deconstruct
um you only know afterwards whether or
not it's something you could have put
back together it's like children with
bicycles very fine at taking them apart
very bad at putting them back together
um not comp comparing Sam to a child but
I mean I just I think that is it is
something you notice only once you've
taken a part once you can't reconstruct
it you realize what what function it
might have performed um I said to Sam on
stage a few years ago uh that I I
thought that it would all be fine if
most atheists were as rational and
levelheaded as Sam but it's not Sam
Harris all the way down it's like Sam
Harris followed by total mentalists and
um who just will not reason or
rationalize anything and are just
screaming harpies of insanity yeah so
that's a shame
um but yes I mean I think that that
whole thing works for some people but
obviously doesn't work for others I mean
religion is you know shophow among
others saw it was um religion was
Philosophy for the
masses um absent religion completely
lots of options of what will happen one
is
the the the the general public lose the
overarching framework of their lives and
have nothing to replace it with and
another one is that they do replace it
with other things you know which are new
religions which crop up all the time we
have the the religion of the body
negativity movement you know we have the
religion of um trans we have the
religion of gender we have the religion
of race and you know and all these
things have just stepped into this void
and they're all dogmatic things where
they're founding texts
um they they've all got their own
catechisms of a Kind priests they
priests they have uh excommunication
rights and I my my only observation
really would be on that is that I
preferred the old gods you know I
preferred the old priesthood finally
enough uh partly because we knew its
flaws and um the sweet point where you
see the flaws of religious belief but
can still live through it
is um is one even I can well I can
especially feel nostalgic for because I
I I don't like the new priesthood I I
find them um uh as corrupt as any
priests would in history uh with the
negative um attribute that that not
everyone's woken up to them yet you know
I mean do we have do we have in our
culture an equivalent for instance of
the meme of the pedophile priest I don't
think we do I mean for instance I would
love it if the the sort of
uh adults who push you know gender
dysmorphia stuff on children were
regarded as the equivalent of pedophile
priests I think that'd be
fine uh but my point it doesn't come
with that yet it's like the Catholic
church in Boston circa
1950 the priests are still fiddling with
the kids but no one wants to talk about
it so in other news this episode is
brought to you by Maui newie venison
Maui Nei venison brings the healthiest
red meat on the planet direct to your
door not only is it the most
nutrient-dense meat on the planet
they're the only 100% stress-free wild
harvested venison that you can get
here's my super secret hack if you are
sick of buying meat that always goes off
put it in the freezer from Frozen salt
both sides of it put it in an air fryer
for 10 to 12 minutes each side and you
have a perfectly cooked steak from
Frozen that will never go off because
it's going from freezer to mouth in the
space of 25 minutes minut it's a
complete Game Changer all of their cuts
are spectacular and you can get them
Frozen delivered to your door but their
venison sticks are my favorite while
I've been on the road you can get the
healthiest red meat on the planet
delivered directly to your door and get
20% off by going to the link in the
description below or heading to mauw
venison tocom modern wisdom and using
the code modern wisdom check out that's
M Au UI Nui venison tocom wisdom and
modern wisdom at checkout it makes me
think think as we were talking earlier
on about
uh some of the ways in which lots of
decisions need to be made and you don't
know how the outcomes are going to occur
that there are no Solutions only
tradeoffs quote I keep coming back to
that in my personal life as well but
thinking about what people want to
optimize for in their
existence there are no Solutions
ultimately like and you have to give up
certain things uh you don't have to give
up everything well no there's certainly
better Solutions but the world is trying
to maximize everything it's there is and
it goes back to the shallow Pond of
empathy
that accepting the trade-offs are an
inevitability doesn't fit into that
Paradigm right it's we will always
optimize for what is what feels most
pleasurable or empathetic in the short
term I know I don't know I don't feel
that well that's what the that's how it
plays out I think for a lot of people
yes if they hav character if they have
no character in well what do you
optimize
for I try to optimize for peace that
seems to be the thing that for me in my
personal life I try to do if the price
is my sanity the cost is too high no
matter what it is and I continually
throw that rule out of the window all
the time that's what I try and aim for
right my own rubric is I love the piece
in your in your private life I try
reminds you of Lady Lady brell's line
about the general at the end of The
Importance of Being Earnest she says the
general was essentially a man of peace
except in his domestic
life you're the other way
around yeah you're a man of peace in
your domestic life except for my maybe
you are generally as well I don't I
don't think I am you're highly agreeable
person [__] not really uh I I I try
as best I can to keep a keep a lid on it
but yeah the um this lack of of meaning
and and people's desire their absolutely
fervent desire to try and fill that hole
with as many things as they
can like lizo like lizo indeed did you
did you see the stories that came out
about lizo oh was wonderful about her
Amsterdam my favorite story of the year
yeah a long way what for the people that
don't know lizza was on tour uh in
Amsterdam uh took her backup dances to
the red light district yes and made the
backup dancers some of the backup
dancers eat bananas out of the vaginas
of amster
strippers my view was what happened here
was that lizo thought you could
Outsource the eating of your five fruit
and vegg
day she to the vagina to the vagina of
the stripper or to the she so reluctant
to eat healthfully she even outsources
the fire fruit and vegg day how's my
view well it seems to me that it's it
seems to me that both lizo uh Ellen
degenerous uh Jimmy Kimmel all of these
people who up front oh isn't it
wonderful it's so great it's always it's
always nice Nic sque not the Liz ever
look nice but like the the squeaky clean
Ellen De generas thing you know just
dance and you know and of course they're
horrible in real life behind theen of
course there's a sort of rule there by
the way actually with public figures is
that the ones who are most you know sort
of sweety sweee in public tend to be the
nastiest in private sometimes the
opposite can be true some people who are
thought to have a very um hard Edge in
public can actually be lovely lovely
people in private like Margaret Thatcher
was a good example very very nice to
people around her you know but could
make tough decisions yeah it's to me
it's a a counter signal if I see someone
doing the lizo thing of I am so body
positivity I it it becomes their
identity of how they're a flaming sword
card carrying Paragon of whatever this
thing is well it's also it's also a bit
like the
um uh the Jimmy savl um uh the hospital
what was it called uh it still goes but
um there was a hospital for children
that he raised money for all the time
and whenever anyone would try to do an
investigation s go oh you know it's
going to it's going to hurt the hospital
for kids you know you sure you want to
run that story well that's going to hurt
the hospital so there are lot lots of
people in our own age who have a thing
like that they build like the equivalent
of the Jimmy savl Children's Hospital
facade up in order to protect themselves
right are you saying that lizzo's work
with the body positivity movement is in
a case to try and effectively put a wall
of large a wall bodied people in front
of very difficult wall to get over well
I think it's probably easy to get over
getting around it might be more
difficult um nor I got into a car and it
ran out of
gas so uh I had this idea about um why
certain women are very Pro body
positivity movement and I was listening
to Bill Burr do a live show and he said
uh ladies if you could only support the
WNBA the way that you support a fat
chick who is gaining weight and no
longer a threat to you that it would be
doing more numbers than the NBA is and I
realized that
some some nonzero number of women May
deep down in their darker moments
realize that they don't discourage some
of their friends from uh gaining weight
yes because they can eat themselves out
of their in seexual competition for
potential partners well come on men are
like that as well how do we play that
game I mean this is going to show a low
side of my character but you you can't
say always that you're sad if a somebody
you're not very close to but you KN knew
you see them after some years and they
and they're
fat I mean you can't say there isn't a
slight sort of you'll never guess he's
become fat there there's different
versions of that with with men I think I
and I I think men can be complicit in
that as well h
yeah you know the thrill when a friend
balds early you know I think that's very
common thrill that needs there'll be a
German word for that of course like
Shard and but specifically for for the
for the scalp yeah yeah yeah yeah scalp
I yeah I think lots of people do that
but it's it's a pretty bad thing to
encourage among people but yeah I think
it is part of the competition take
taking out of the competition for sure I
was thinking as well about how uh
material conditions you were saying
before people's parents
maybe had it better in some ways but
also would have had it way worse yeah of
course material
conditions often don't impact people's
demeanors in the way that they might
have predicted like rich people can be
bitter idiots and poor people can be
grateful Heroes although George Orwell
said by the age of 50 every man gets the
face he deserves what do you mean by
that I think that's actually true I
think there's a certain age it might not
be 50 now but it's a certain age where
you do show your life on your your face
M oh yeah I mean for instance somebody
who's very profoundly depressed for a
long time that writes itself across the
face it writes itself in their eyes I
think um PE particularly unhappiness
writes itself on somebody's face Joy
does as well I mean if somebody if
somebody smiles a lot they have laugh
lines you know and
um yes it's there's a great truth in it
I mean we we know that because we we
judge people by their faces by the way
they interact with us by the way they
look at us it's perfectly
sensible I found a quote the other day
that said uh people with low self-esteem
will always find a way to be
miserable and it made me think that uh
material conditions a lot of the time or
what young people but many people lay at
the feet of their despondency or their
nihilism or their critical nature or
whatever it might be and I've seen
enough of my
friends vacillate through varying levels
of uh affluence or or or relationship or
singlet tenness or whatever uh and one
of the things sometimes it impacts the
way that they show up but many times
they are the common denominator between
all of those situations and the material
conditions don't actually impact the way
that they show up all that much that's
true well there's a problem of analyzing
this which is that anyone who's
successful inevitably looks at their own
path to success as being to some extent
pre-ordained I mean almost I mean if you
just get there were some people with
wild luck but most people a lot of
people let me say who who are successful
uh look back and they think well I don't
understand this person who hasn't made
it to the same rung of the ladder as I
have why didn't they work hard so
there's a sort of um uh callousness
actually that can creep in there um but
equally uh people are to a great extent
master of their own fate and it's it's
it's a very hard one to analyze that as
I said because the out Riders skew the
whole statistics I mean the The outrider
Who does very well not everyone can do
what he or she has done but he or she is
likely to think they could have done
well you retroactively lots of people
that achieved success look back at the
route that was particularly designed by
them for them to achieve the very
specific type of success that they
managed to get and then retrofit that as
a universal law that anybody else could
follow one of the things I've realized
is I've spent more time digging into
personal growth and self-development and
all of that stuff so much of it is post
rationalization about one person's very
very idiosyncratic solution for this
thing and they say these are the
universal principles of X Y and Z and
you go no they're not no they W highly
personal it's your personality just spun
up and tuned up to 11 yeah I mean most
very successful people I've ever met
have some story o of their own growth
which is both inspiring and not
replicable well unusual people but
what's the alternative as you said
before like you have to lay the agency
at your own feet because if you were to
perhaps admit the truth which is I was
in the right place at the right time was
well there's a yeah that can be the case
not many people say that but yeah some
do yeah yeah yeah if you're in Britain
in the ' 80s for instance it was a good
time to make money easier
better um than today so some people will
say yeah it was a great place at the
right time but most people do sort of
vaguely think if they've made it that
they it was sort of pre-ordained I I I
will do that to some extent I often
describe myself as being lucky and then
need somebody to remind me of how hard
I've worked no I had a friend who joined
Goldman Sachs in
1998 MH and he said he had an absolute
golden period for about for yeah yeah a
little bit less uh he said it was
already starting to wind down before
Layman brother yeah um some of that was
to do with Dei a very early
instantiation of Dei that's right yes
there there's several books that make
that clear in sub text yeah several
books that make it clear about some of
the hiring processes going on yeah like
2006 he was already seeing it but he
told me uh he made a trade uh on uh 911
he made he made a very particular trade
and uh bypassed all of the
security um concern the limits on
everything and the Pit Boss or what
whatever he's just some young dude he's
been there for two years right out of
whatever University or something what
did his boss think of the trade came
over and said like what the [__] are you
doing and he said look at this if this
then that if this then that run it all
the way down he said this is the outcome
this is what's going to happen and he's
like we like I I don't know what so
first off he was concerned that it was
going to go wrong and then he made the
most ungodly amount of money in the
space of three hours and then all the
market shut for 10 days from from
September 12th and uh the only
organization that had spare Capital was
Goldman because of this particular trade
wow and uh he was basically told we may
need to cut this I'll check with him he
was basically told go home don't tell
anybody yeah of course that you made
this he shorted the market yeah I mean
it was it was widely thought off 911
that because the the stock market tanked
of course immediately and we didn't know
if there was going to be a World War if
this was World War um and um uh it was
regarded very swiftly as actually being
the duty of Wall Street to to not do
that but Bush came back you remember he
did that ground zero announcement we
will do and that was as much for the uh
stock market as it was for the [__]
popular yeah absolutely well yes because
I mean stock market collapses I mean
many many more Americans I can't
remember the
percentage are invested in the stock
market than in Britain I mean like three
times more or something America
401 yeah more than 50% of the population
in America has some uh investment in the
in the stock market so it's different
from in the UK where when the when when
the pound was shorted in the 1990s by uh
um Soros and others uh they
um a lot of British people are not that
sympathetic because they don't see
themselves as being involved in the
stock market which because they are they
just don't know it you mentioned George
oal the the telegraph recently spoke
about his by his wife wife's biography
or autobiography oh there's a new
biography of Sonia Orwell yeah George
Orwell was sadistic misogynistic
homophobic and sometimes violent
biographer of the legendary writer's
wife says darkness that runs through
1984 is a reflection of his soul should
we unperson George well it would be the
obvious end point to the full circle
full circle
um yeah I I this is just a way of the
for the author to get publicity is to to
repeat things every knew I mean George
Orwell held the views of his time about
gay men for instance we know he was a
little bit homophobic but was the 1940s
you know um Nancy boys and so on as you
would have called them were not you know
people weren't that sounds like like a a
1990s taxi driver's insult that they've
thrown it was a sort of word that all
well and people his generation would use
you know fairies that sort of thing and
he does in some of his letters and some
of his articles but I mean so [__]
what I don't
care I mean was he sadistic
probably in some ways
sometimes was could he be cruel and
nasty probably being a human
being I just think that the absurdity of
our age of judging people and the P well
you know just just wait till people do
that to you yeah you know wait wait till
somebody weighs up your
own life in the balance and finds you
wanting
you know I mean I think it's
Preposterous human beings are what we
are being amazed at us in the past is
always just an expression of our own
vanity and thinking we've got past all
that it's like the way if a friend of
mine was saying to me the other day when
I was at Oxford if you want to get a
grant to study these days say in English
and you were to choose Shakespeare as
your subject of study which is sort of
unusual these days uh you would um you
would for inance have to find
Shakespeare guilty of you know racism
colonialist thinking and so on and it
doesn't seem to strike these people that
actually their job is not to judge
Shakespeare Shakespeare judges us and he
might find us wanting how
so well he gives us visions of the
universe and our place in it which it
would do us well to listen to
um and that might include exposing human
human weakness human Pride human sin
human lust the tendency to do evil in
the name of doing good or think you're
doing good and do great
harm so much more all of this is in
Shakespeare's work in his characters in
the things he in he created in his mind
and his work I think that that if you
look at a panoply of a vision like that
you should think I wonder what he's
telling us rather than I wonder how I
can judge him what's the point of the
latter it's so boring human being from
the past inhuman being in the past
shocker has it always been this way has
it always been uh people of the present
judging people of Yesterday by the
standards of today um well most people
didn't have time in the past to engage
in that um too busy trying to put food
on the
table was surviving past the age of
25 you know
um uh but what what it is in our current
Society is there's a very strange um um
lack of respect for wisdom uh Henry kiss
just said this in the early years of the
internet he said all the knowledge is
there but where's the wisdom people
might not like me quoting Dr Kissinger
in that regard
but again he knows a lot more than most
of his critics um I do think that's a
that's a Oddity of the age I think the
Oddity the vanity of trying to judge
everyone from the past but our current
standards is just absurd you think you
know more than Shakespeare think you
know more than
Orwell uh these are
minnows uh snapping Giants I don't care
for
them one uh potentially unfortunate
situation is that women's mental health
is in part down to misogynistic songs
when BTS lead singer Yung cook changed
to a more misogynistic music disturbing
Trend followed a psychiatrist's point of
view on bts's young cook and the the
messages of pop music early in their
teen career BTS took a deliberate stance
to refrain from objectifying or
sexualizing women despite going against
a music industry Norm they achieved huge
success now as part of his solo launch
different imagery has surfaced in Jung
cook songs they include a woman telling
of her man that she will be your fantasy
and swallow your pride to make him never
think about cheating lyrics that
identify what's why you said swallow
your pride in a particularly suggestive
way I've got I've got more to go here uh
lyrics that identify women as those hoes
over there and a male rapper telling his
female partner I wanked before you came
so that I can [__] you longer of course
in reality Yung Cook's songs are part of
the course or even tame does that work
by the way what you just described
you've You' never increased your stamina
by having a warmup I would have thought
the lyric more likely I did that before
you game and I just let to get a
better that kind like a lie down I did
that before you came that's why I texted
saying I'm not so F yeah don't mind I
have a quick dinner and then I'll go to
bed one of my friends had a uh had a a
rubric for this that was masturbate
before you
evaluate oh well that's true yeah that's
that can be sensible advice I'm not sure
if I liked you or I was just horny horny
yeah yeah but no girls Mental Health you
were reading out these Charming lyrics
those hoes over there I wanked before
you came so that I can [__] you
longer well where to start Downstream
from K-pop is a Litany of female mental
health problems that's what I'm
saying there's a problem here isn't
there because on the one hand popular
culture does have a massive impact on
the way we see the
world uh I was at a gym recently where I
actually asked the gym staff to turn off
the music because it was a load of very
unpleasant rap with a repeated use of
the NW in it obviously he was a black
rapper or so I was assuming right um You
didn't find yourself mouthing along to
the lyrics worried about no but actually
I know that's right what what problem
could possibly emerg from singing along
just to interject there someone got
canceled on Tik Tok for mouthing the
nword along to a song right so it's it's
no possible it's no longer the sound of
the word it's the mouth shape yes that
that word
engenders um well we know that it's a
magical word in our time which even the
speaking of suddenly summons up the
Demons of the past Lord Voldemort yeah
very very strange but no I just said to
this I said to the gym I I said I just
don't want to hear it because I don't
want I just don't want it in the
background of my life you know um was it
that gym that we trained
at we can discuss this another time but
anyway um no I just don't like there are
certain things I don't want to my ear
and that's one actually I have no
interest in hearing the word because
it's a banned word so why would I want
it in my mental background yeah um but
so but anyway the point is is of course
popular culture has a huge impact on
people it has a huge impact on the way
in which people see themselves it does
it
does at the same time you can overstate
it you know somebody is not generally
unhappy just because of the popular
culture apart from anything else because
you can easily step out of it as I try
to do um and you know be a part of your
your time but not be its creature as
Shila says um and so no I I think it's a
sort of weak excuse for unhappiness the
popular culture happens not to be to
your taste or avoid it get out look up
from the screen when is canel culture
going to come for rap lyrics because it
seems to me that you know as we're
fighting against the misogyny of air
conditioning temperatures in offices
that are conditioned to the male body
temperature as opposed to the female
body temperature or I mean the
the the levity of the era is just
astonishing to me you know lots of
people attribute to me this quote that
it's not quite right I don't it's quite
for me but that um that we'll be talking
about gender pronouns when The
Barbarians break in but I've said
something like it quite a few times but
I
mean you know gender norms and air
conditioning it's a sort of thing that
you would be discussing just before you
will get you know
macheted I'm totally serious about this
it's sometimes it's
like one of the things that actually
genuinely shocked me in recent weeks
particular after the Hamas massacre in
Israel was you know and then something
which I do think at some point when when
it's all died down a bit might there
might be a moment of of
of H what youve I've got to say this
carefully but a moment of um serious
which is you know take the music first
of all within a few miles of the Gaza
border that hamad's attacked all the
young people there this sort of Peace
Rave and um this isn't in any way to
victim blame these are people just
wanting to dance and um dance into the
early morning and I think it was called
the peace Rave the peace and love Rave
something like that um and then this
hideous other world broke into to them
into their lives and ended the lives of
hundreds of them there's something
there's something haunting about this I
find because it's uh especially haunting
because it sort of demonstrates that
your slogans and your
attitudes only go so far and they can't
keep out some of the things that are
lurking at the
edges and I think that when I hear
people whining about minor
things if you have any idea of the world
out there if you had any idea of the
things that was lurking You couldn't
possibly be complaining about this well
how do you think gays for Gaza will get
on long term well the joke at the moment
is there aren't enough tall buildings in
Gaza to throw gays for Gaza
off
but these I mean these people are you
know I've said very often they're
they're part of the same phenomenon as
turkeys for Christmas and chickens for
KFC see I mean I just I fed up these in
Fringe idiot cases I mean they're so
mentally defective these people uh and
and Incredibly narcissistic you know I
can be queer and also celebrate panis
now you [__] can't [__]
off
just you know I can both argue for a
two-state solution and also celebrate
queerness and also not let myself down
no you can't no you can't you can't all
those things at some point you got to
choose I've got a video to show you show
you this
video can someone please explain to me
what this means what does reproductive
Justice Means free Palestine what does
that even mean like what does it mean
I'm pretty sure I'm not pretty sure
abortions are
illegal in Palestine unless it's like
you know a super medical emergency and
the mother will die from what I
understand actually a lot of
Palestinians have to go to Israel to get
the abortions they want so what does
this
mean yeah what it it's such a huge
sign there's five people holding this
thing it's
massive that's very good that's Danny
the other half of Ryan who wasn't there
the day that you that you came um voice
cast reproductive Justice Means free
Palestine what do you think can you this
is this is just incredibly ignorant
young people in America who have been
taught this weird version of the world
where all oppressions Interlink and
interlock and you you're either the
majority of the minority for minority
rights and issues or for majority rights
and issues and all minority rights and
issues intersect and overlap so that if
you're queer somehow you well no it's
not even that these ignoramuses who
couldn't point to the River Jordan if
you showed it to them on a map map um
walk along the streets from AR you know
from The River To The Sea Palestine will
be free because I think the Palestinians
are the underdogs in this weird version
where they've mapped American racial
well they've mapped a very specific
version of American racial politics onto
everything else in the world it's the
same thing who talk people who talk
about
colonizers I mean there's this language
of colonizers a partide all this stuff
and they've just tried to map it
everywhere well I say everywhere
actually it's highly selectively highly
selectively I mean the people who are
talking about Israelis being
colonizers um when I saw that the other
day on the Streets of London I thought
yes if only there was a name for large
numbers of people who came from outside
to a
country and um if only we could identify
what they might be called in
Britain oh it would be immigrants
wouldn't it do you want to call
immigrants colonizers in Britain you
sure you want to follow this logical
conclusion the talk about indigenous
peoples oh okay great anywh you don't
want to apply that might there be a
country or continent say oh Europe where
you don't want to start talking about
the indigenous peoples I noticed that
people don't but if you do want
to Welcome to
Hell so no all that is happening is a
very selective mapping of a particular
interpretation of the world that very
dumb people in America have tried to put
on certain selective cases and it
doesn't work it just doesn't work but
may they never find out how much it
doesn't work may they never find
out um I I wish some Bliss in their
ignorance because if their ignorance
ever gets popped it will be as brutal a
day as Can Be
Imagined I've been thinking for a good
while about how hypocrisy is a
purpose-built tool for the internet to
use it's it's like cnip for the Internet
it's the thing because the reason it's
so purpose built it's like a one of
those Can you spot the difference
competitions on a touchscreen iPad this
is what's on the left this is what's on
the right and what you have is here's
something that someone once said or a
position that they used to hold and here
is what they hold now or here is what
they do in their real life or here is
whatever and it's kind of what you're
identifying here that you have a
worldview which is self-contradictory
you're just using different words for
one thing that is almost exactly the
same for another thing right and then
complaining about this one saying don't
look don't don't look over here at this
one yeah well I mean everyone is
inconsistent to some extent and I don't
think by the way that I mean I mean on
hypocrisy or you know for instance I can
see a scenario where somebody might say
oh Douglas you're hypocritical on this
particular question I might say well you
know there are some things I think are
even more important than not being a
hypocrite such as I don't know
surviving I the worst thing about him is
hypocrisy and there's a there's a weird
hypocrisy is the easiest one to catch
people on is the truth of that correct
yes it's easiest one to spot yes um you
just and and they they do it as you say
on this is what this person said 20
years ago this is what they say now okay
again human being in growing up shocker
yes yeah um people are allowed to evolve
they change their minds they grow up be
rather boring to say the same thing and
think the same thing only for 70 years
um
but yeah people find hypocrisy very very
easy to to see and it's about the only
Vice you can really catch somebody on I
think which is if you say one thing
publicly and do another thing privately
it's about the only one that people are
really confident on uh or most other
moral judgments For Better or Worse have
sort of Eed way but people still are
able to judge uh
hypocrisy um uh but I think I I mean I I
think there were worse things I I think
not standing up for your loved ones not
standing up for your country not
standing up for uh yourselves in the
face of horrible opposition from within
without of probably worse than hypocrisy
I heard you say recently you don't have
to agree with everyone's principle to
respect the principle they're sticking
to did I say that yeah sounds good yeah
it's nice okay I I didn't know I said
that but yeah you did uh but the reason
that I like that is I think it
shows
why
The Bravery conversation or standing up
for something that you believe in is
something that is a at least then if
someone is prepared to stand up for
whatever their beliefs are that you can
assume they're telling the truth
especially if they pay a high price for
it it's one of the reasons why I have uh
a good amount of faith that Sam believes
the things that he says why would he not
he pays an unbelievably high price to
continue to flip-flop from One Tribe to
another tribe to another tribe I don't
think it's an unbelievably high price
but a price let's say relatively high
price
yeah yeah I I I mean very early in some
people's careers or when people first
make it to public notice people say
things like you know do you really
believe what you say the answer to which
for most people is or ought to be well
why would I say it if I didn't believe
it uh there are people who obviously do
say stuff for LOLs or clicks or manitary
purpose but at a certain point I mean
you you got to accept that the person
thinks what they think and you know
respect them for it or at least do them
the decency of believing that they mean
it and I think that even on people I
disagree with wildly I mean it's such a
boring argument that one some people use
it particularly on the left is like you
know I wonder if they actually even
believe it I think they don't I think
they're just doing it for money okay
well that's an easier way to try to
ignore them than actually trying to
contend with the possibility that what
they're saying is something they mean
and believe and trying to work out if
there's anything in it much easier to
say the person's only doing it because
they're paid or something yeah that's
the shill grifter accusation very boring
accusation yeah I don't doubt there are
some people who who that is the case
with but way fewer than way fewer than
people think Michael malice has a a
hierarchy of different uh I think it's
like the hierarchy of grifters don't
know why the moment you say Michael mice
my face immediately sort of starts to
smile yeah it's terrible one of the it's
like um industry plant paid opposition
controlled scop he goes all the way up
and he said that he descended recently
he's not quite at paid opposition but I
think he's industry plant now I think
Lex Freedman is paid opposition um his
paid is different from controlled
opposition maybe it's controlled
opposition I don't [__] know
controlled opposition is these are such
weird terms that have cropped up in our
era I love it again I think there sort
of low resolution explanations for
really really low resolution
explanations for things whenever I hear
somebody describe things as that I
always sort of know you're not dealing
with somebody who actually understands
the world do you find there's a
definitely a trend of
um conspiratorial thinking conspiracism
uh much stronger in our adopted Homeland
than it is in the UK I think yes that's
true what do you think are you how
conspiracy pilled are you do you
see I mean it's it's this is the moment
when people say ah controlled
opposition You' ascended this is me
allowing you to graduate I think I
talked about this on the boys cast
that's right and and briefly and and and
uh various people wrote to me saying ah
there you go that's proof you're paid
you're glowing as it's called but it's
what's it you're you heard you're
glowing no what's that so tell me if I'm
wrong with this Mark you're the resident
glow expert but you're glowing means
you're you're like
a
planted person who's saying something
that is outing their like
oh it's an intelligence operation that's
that's breached the surface and people
can see it they comment on Tik Tok
saying like you're glowing oh it's it's
like um the people alleged to be FBI um
who are at certain protest or wearing
chinos and t-shirts yeah um so you're
conspiratorial so the conspiracy the
thing with conspiracy theories is very
difficult in our era cuz some of the
conspiracies are true of course have
come true um well known to be true uh
lab Le conspiracy theory probably true
they shouldn't have ever called nobody
should ever have called it a conspiracy
theory because it wasn't a conspiracy
theory it was one of a set of hypo of
hypotheticals to explain what happened
with uh with uh with coid um so a lot of
things get called conspiracy which are
not they're just hypotheses uh that
should be allowed to remain on the table
and that makes a certain type of person
increasingly prone to uh believe that
everything that's called conspiracy
theory is not conspiracy theory and
before you know it you get sanish
individuals thinking that the moon
landings were a conspiracy we didn't
land on the moon the American didn't
land on the moon I don't know whether
the people who now claim that believe
that the Russians also faked it it's an
interesting question to ask them do you
think the the that the Soviets were
capable of getting to the moon but the
Americans were not the Americans set up
like a a blow fan and a flag on a dodgy
papia mese set but the Soviets did make
it or did the and Americans both agree
to pretend to have gone to the moon but
not really have gone none of it makes
sense to my mind but there's this but
but but it's I have noticed and well
it's actually all the literature
demonstrates is that there's certain
types of mental um uh uh problems that
people have that make them
disproportionately likely to believe
conspiracy theories on on mass and one
of them is parano uh the more paranoid a
person is the more likely they to
believe that sort of thing and that's
the observation in my own life I've I've
known a number of people who who've gone
into the world of conspiracy and not
come out and they are all people who
have suffered paranoid episodes in their
lives so which adds up so fear and
genders yeah and it's as I say it's a
sort of low resolution explanation for
complex
phenomena uh and you know and I think
it's also that see conspiracy theories
come about and and are used by people
who and this is isn't an original Point
many people have made it they're made
the the claims about them are made by
and large by people who don't understand
how unbelievably chaotic the world
actually is or can't face
it um so they can't face the fact that
yeah somebody you followed in the
newspapers every day all of your life
did actually just die in a freak car
crash because the driver was drunk they
can't bear the idea the world can't be
that cruel it can't be that random you
want a bed it's got to be coordination
it can't be coincidence exactly so
people who can't cope with the wild
fality of the roulette table of Our
Lives um always go to the there must be
somebody behind it there must be
somebody who's controlling all this you
you joking nobody's controlling this if
anyone's controlling the damn thing I'd
want to know by now but of course
they're not it's it's so it's a very
unsatisfactory place to arrive at in
your life and by the way my own
observation is not very good for people
personally because they they start to
lose agency themselves locus of control
gets externalized I'm at the mercy of
the world yeah and the real answer is
the world doesn't care no doesn't even
know that you exist it is deaf to you
the the ability for people to hold two
conflicting thoughts in their mind at
the same time is supposed to be the mark
of of sophisticated thinking but it does
show up here which is the government is
both so useless that they can't get
anything right and so sophis icated that
they were able to coordinate masses of
versions the Arab world is filled with
that the Muslim world is filled with
that things like I've noticed it's
repeated the on my travels things like
um uh 911 was an inside job of the
Americans to allow the Jews out of the
World Trade Center and also yay 911 good
for bin Laden they can do
both uh there was a somebody I knew
interviewed the father of um the main
9/11 hijacker is name has gone out of my
mind I don't care he must he should be
forgotten but interviewed the father in
Jordan and he was simultaneously capable
of holding in his head that his son was
a great Shahid the M for
Islam and that 911 was an inside job
with the
Americans well what the [__] like
choose it's I mean do you think your son
was an agent of the FBI and also a Marty
like hey people do this the Muslim world
is particularly Pro to to conspiratorial
thinking because it's a it's a source of
flattery to itself to explain why they
have created so few successful
societies um and and Bernard Lewis made
this point many years ago that the
problem in the Muslim world is that
there's a they they have to find
explanations because if you're given the
revelations of Muhammad and you're told
it's the last Revelation ever from God
and that you are the people who have
received this Revelation and
everything's going to go great for you
because you've got the Revelation and
then like the Jews you have one country
and it does much better than any of your
countries and you know you can't get the
economy of most of your countries going
at all and you can't provide for most
your citizenry and nobody's coming up
the ladder and the economies in the dust
and all this you've got to find an
explanation for it because like what we
were given the Revelation and they're
doing much better I mean there's massive
things like that that sit underneath the
movements of our time
which maybe billions of people on the
planet believe and they believe them
because it flatters themselves it
flatters the governments who aspire to
run these countries or claim to run
these
countries um yeah billions of people
believe this [__] I was thinking about
the extremist worldview beliefs largely
in the west but I guess everywhere and I
was wondering whether we have finally
moved Beyond Peak woke and a study came
up recently that was kind of interesting
researchers from change research pulled
over a thousand registered us voters
from 18 to 34 a majority of both women
and men consider far rightism and far-
leftism to be red flags in a potential
partner 76% of women and 59% of men
consider identifying as a Maga
Republican to be a large turnoff 64% of
men and 55% of women said they'd also
swipe left on someone identifying as a
communist 55% of women 64% of men 55% of
women swipe left on Earth on a communist
that to know uh 55% of men said that
listening to Joe Rogan was a red flag uh
41% of men said the same for a woman
being into astrology oh that's that I
I'm with that one uh got if somebody
says what's your star sign date
over there's a a really famous meme
where uh it's on iMessage and the text
says um Mom uh what time was I born at
and the reply mom says uh stay the [__]
away from that
girl yeah it is it is the heart sinks
when it comes up as the question oh no a
shame uh 41 33% of men said for black
lives matter it was a red flag if they
say black lives matter 14% of women 53%
of women said it was a red flag if they
rece refus to see the Barbie movie uh
31% of men 58% of women red flag if they
say there are only two genders 34% of
men uh 54% of women for they identify as
a conservative uh 33% of men for they
identify as a liberal uh so next time
you're vibing with someone maybe save
the podcast recommendations and daily
horoscopes for the second date wow it
55% of women say that listening to Joe
Rogan was a red flag I wonder if the
species has any future because they
can't listen to Joe Rogan well like all
these people are wiping out like very
significant numbers of potential future
Partners
um how weird and Joe turning up in that
55% so that's amazing I thought what
happened to all the good old people who
used to say I don't really have an
opinion on that well I what happened to
those guys I got pulled in a good bit
recently on the internet for uh not
commenting on the recent
sociopolitical feral that's happening in
the Middle East and I quoted you
pseudonymously and said uh I'm trying to
make a habit of something which is very
rare on the internet to not comment on
something which I know nothing about
it's very good
Rule and yet it's the rarest thing of
all why shouldn't I people people care
about my insights into health and
fitness or uh my my learnings about
social psychology why why shouldn't my
fiscal advice be important why why
shouldn't my views on immigration or
it's much to be avoided that and I mean
in the end you make much less of a dick
of yourself if you don't start talking
about everything I mean there's um I
mean somebody recently sent me an
article a relatively well-known person
sent me an article recently they wanted
to publish about the Middle East and
near the opening said um I don't really
know much about the Middle East but you
this is and I was just say in that case
don't speak don't speak and say but
here's my thing if you don't know just
just just agree not to do it um that's
one reason why there's a lot of I mean
there's a lot of Television these days
in the UK where you can be invited on to
debate the total ignoramus who's only
there for balance you know offc com
related balance and I just can't do that
stuff anymore it's too
demeaning you know that if there's a
subject you know about a war that you've
covered or covered many times as in my
case with Israel hamz Wars and Israel
hpah Wars um I I just can't be sitting
there with somebody I hate to say this
it's not not meant in a misogynistic way
but there's a lot of um uh women who are
currently voted on things for balance
firstly because they're women secondly
because they provide usually a leftwing
perspective and that that's needed if
it's me that's on as well and you know I
just it's so depressing to you know to
give your informed opinion about
something you've seen and reported on
firsthand and and then they go to the
other person and they go well like I
think
it's I say oh why I don't why aren I
just at
home why I could be doing anything else
and I've got to listen to somebody who
doesn't know what they're talking about
whisk up an opinion live on air that's
so depressing but masses of people are
like that and it's
just yeah if you don't know about it
don't talk about it it's a very good Ro
TH or try it out in private with friends
and mates and like try to learn
something read a
book are we morally obliged to have a
take on everything no no most people's
opinion doesn't matter I mean it just
doesn't and I also think the people who
spend their time online broadly
speaking you know trying to broadcast
cast out their opinions on things should
be told more often doesn't
matter um doesn't matter what you think
I mean one of my rules on on any war is
you should never as a writer try to give
advice to a government you know this is
what the Israelis must do this is what
the ukrainians must
do they need to listen to you I mean
first of all you don't live in the
country and unless you live in a country
be pretty damn sure Sur they should be a
bit humble about telling other people
about their lives you know and also like
who made you the tactician dour on
everything well it was the same as Co
everyone became a virology or
epidemiology expert yeah and then they
became an withdrawal from Afghanistan
expert and then they became a Ukraine
expert and now they're all Middle East
experts and I just think it's a it
should be regarded as a massive red flag
that the person in question question is
normally what's happened is they've
downloaded uh the set of opinions they
believe that their tribe should have
correct and that's why the morons
marching in London and other cities you
know with the exception of the Muslims
who just whipped up all the time by the
fact that the Jews do anything I mean
like Muslims don't care about other
Muslims Arabs don't care about other
Arabs nobody cares about the
Palestinians nobody cares about them
can't tell you how little they care
about them jordanians loathe them the
Egyptians loathe them the Lebanese
loathe them they've done nothing the
Palestinians for 70 years and yet
whenever the Israelis do
anything the Muslims across the West
come out on streets because they hate
the Jews and you know hundreds of
thousands of people have been killed in
Yemen not a peep on the streets of
Britain and other places certainly not
big protests uh Bashar al-assad has
killed more Muslims in the last 10 years
than then everybody on every side killed
in every war involving Israel since 1948
including the war of independence nobody
cares the Muslims don't come out on the
streets they don't care the only thing
they care about is their hatred of the
Jews and it motivates them like nothing
else because it hits at the core of
their self-esteem they can't bear it and
so that one is like very interesting to
me but the there are these fellow
Travelers who go along with them who
have downloaded as I say as sort of
pathe IC American interpretation of
colonization decolonization racial
Justice Reproductive Rights and try to
map everything on and my friend's Got a
Theory called gwi's theory of bespoke
[__] many don't have an opinion
until they're asked for it at which
point they Cobble together a Viewpoint
from whim and half-remembered hearsay
before deciding that this twom minute M
two-minute old makeshift opinion will be
their new Hill to die on it's very good
my friend fairy great at this but
spectator TS tends to run very popular
pieces each time a new big thing emerges
which is the bluffers guide to whatever
and it's great and usually involves in
foreign policy us usually involves
saying things like well they better get
this done before the brutal Afghan
winter kicks
in who made you an expert on like
meteorology in Afghanistan like what oh
no the ukrainians have got to make this
Advance before the dreaded Ukrainian
May and they just what I I mean I try
bluffer guide yeah it's very useful rule
I I I try for instance never to write
about any foreign policy is if it's
about a country I've not visited
preferably visited multiple times I I
just I can't bring myself to do it I
find it too embarrassing it's so
interesting when you talk about um
knowing one opinion that a person holds
and from that one opinion being able to
accurately predict everything else that
they believe yeah that mono thinking
just proves that you're not a serious
thinker well I I just it's fairly
obvious if for instance you say yeah
what's the problem with a big bearded
guy winning the weight women's
weightlifting I go okay I know all of
your other opinions as well and to be
fair that probably works the other way
around as well to a great extent the
interesting thing with most people is
where they're um slightly out of sorts
with their own political side and well
that's exactly the point
that you if it's been a long time since
you were surprised by the opinion of
your favorite thinker or writer or
commentator or whatever it is that's
probably a reliable signal that they're
not really thinking for themselves yeah
if you're just permanently oh yeah it's
like an old leather pair of shoes here
we go again the the coid things happened
and I can already predict such and
such's opinion on it you go every single
time all of the time every single time
you know the idiosyncrasies of this
person's very very particular worldview
well that's because it's not theirs yeah
of course it's everybody else's it's
outsourced thinking and that what's
really sad about that is that uh it
means that you're not really living your
life I mean you're living a pasti of a
prescribed set of opinions that's so sad
I mean it's so sad the wasted energies
and wasted lives of people who've just
downloaded a set of opinions and they
just they're just running them well
that's not your life it's just someone
else's life you're just replaying
what was that quote you talk me about
about being shunted to the side of the
road of your own it's a Philip Lin quote
from a poem for his yes description of a
couple and he says that something is
pushing them to the side of their own
lives it's beautiful line terrifying
line horrifying line should make
everyone judge themselves what's it mean
to
you oh well it means that there's a life
that you hoped to live you life you saw
yourself living and and you you got
pushed to the side of it and ended up
not living that
life I I think a large number of people
have that almost all unhappy people I've
met have that feeling to some extent and
then you've got a choice of poisons one
of which is to choose the poison of um
other people held me
back another is to face up to the fact
that you in some way a
coward or a victim of circumstance or
something else but I think a lot I mean
you know you know one thing that young
people you know can be encouraged to do
is to set out the sort of Life they
would like to live imagine the sort of
Life they would like to live and then
aim for it and um working it out is
sometimes difficult sometimes not but if
you do have that image of your life that
you think it should be lived and you end
up not living it that that is if you can
feel yourself slowly being pushed away
from it I think that's a terrible
terrible feeling it's like watching your
own demise occur second by second yeah
fortunately I've never felt it but I
definitely fear it where do you go to
find or to avoid cowardice or to find
resilience or or bravery because a lot
of the time the easier path is easier
and it's the one that's got the least
resistance and surround yourself with
courageous
people surround yourself with um with
brave
people and that can be bravery of all
sorts of different kinds and when I
turned 40 I had a a dinner uh which I
think you weren't invited too but it's
only because you weren't in town if I
remember rightly but I did get a lot of
my favorite people in the room at least
and it was interesting
that uh a friend made a speech in which
he said it's striking I won't say the
names of the people around the table but
some of whom will be familiar to
listeners but a friend of mine gave a
rather very touching speech I was very
moved by it which he said how noticeable
it was that Douglas has surrounded
himself with courageous people and it
was from a very wide ARR array of bits
of the world and different disciplines
and so on and I was really touched by
that because I hadn't particularly
noticed that I'd done it um but then I
realized I sort of had that actually yes
I had must have subconsciously but maybe
now consciously wanted to be around
courageous people because I think that
courage is something that rubs off on
other people I think it's enormously to
be desired to to be around courageous
people and that might be different types
of Courage some of it physical some of
it
mental um so that that's one thing yeah
surround yourself with courageous people
or at least not uh cowards not kettin
not the sort of people who just say the
same things that everyone's meant to say
and so on there many ways people can get
out of this non-life that they are being
shunted into one of my friends he wasn't
a friend at the time I'd just met him
for the first time but someone that I've
been interested in for a good while uh I
met in Austin a while ago
and he'd had a interesting story and
he'd faced the cancellation over the
last few years and he sort of told me
the story and he said uh who sat on some
rooftop late at night talking about this
thing and he was regaling me with the
story he said throughout my entire life
I thought I was a hard man I like to do
man things and surround myself with
masculine people and I was into you know
like guns and shooting and fitness and
and friends with Navy Seals and all the
rest of it he said my entire life I was
scared that I was a
coward terrified that I was a coward and
he said
uh in my darker moments I could always
hear my better self clearing his throat
in the room next door
beautiful and then this cancellation
thing came along and he said you know
even even the people that do really hard
things hard intellectual work hard
training work hard physical work all the
rest of it there's a difference in the
kind of difficulty that they do because
it's elected right you've chosen to do
the hard workout but when the entire
world comes to bear on you in a way that
feels like chaos and catastrophe whipped
up into a whirlwind and he said uh yeah
I that was a genuine test and he was he
was very grateful he said my my my
better self stopped his coughing and
kicked the door in and came to help good
uh which but just yeah I could always
hear my better self clearing his throat
in the room next door well the thing
with that is uh um the difference
between um uh situations you find
yourself in that are dangerous through
choice and ones that you've uh into yeah
been thrust into and probably know that
that that the consequence of being
thrust into danger situation is much
more likely to lead to um PTSD and
things like that um than if you choose
to um and uh I've been fortunate in my
life the most dangerous situations I've
been being in of being ones I've chosen
to be in um and that's that's very
different
um but yes I'm well I'm glad he found
out that he was more courageous than he
feared but think about that what a
beautiful line you know to be to be more
courageous than you feared you were
right you know this this almost this war
against
yourself yes that's this fear of your
own nature well that but that it's
perfectly sense I mean there a as a
horrible example I sometimes use but I
mean um
if you're ever mugged for your wallet
let alone you're mugged with somebody
else let alone if you're mugged with a
girl that you were with or looking after
and you just handed it over they're like
there's there's several reasons that
it's worth handing over the wallet for
one of which is like why do I need to
risk getting shot for like or stabbed or
stabbed for 100 100 bucks and a few
phone calls to the bank yeah so that's
like the reason to hand over the wallet
what do I
care uh the reason reason not to hand
over the
wallet uh is are you sure that you're
not going to spend the succeeding weeks
Dreaming Dreams of pornographic violence
against your
attacker and thinking thinking of how
you're going you would torture him if
you could get your hands on him and the
brutal way in which you would have
Revenge if you ever find him it might be
easier to just get your head kicked in a
bit yes and are you sure you can live
with the version of yourself that is you
handing over the wallet I said this
recently in a piece of New York post
about the people on the New York Subway
where there's this awful thing you've
probably seen where people you know like
a woman will be being abused by some
Maniac fenel adult you know um drug
addict and and you know people like
either look into their phones including
men or they will get their phones up and
like
record and I mean somebody said Douglas
is trying to get people killed and I
wasn't obviously but what I was saying
was where are the men just like stand up
and like confront the guy if he's got a
Woman by her hair and is parading her
around the
carriage and yeah the the back lash was
like what do you know these people might
get killed if they step in but M say
yeah but also maybe we'll have a more
Civil Society if people don't think they
can go around and do this stuff without
consequence um I'd like to see far more
standing up like that I think it's a
pathetic position for particularly for
men to be in to sit there like getting
out their mobile
phones but you know it's everyone's
choice I don't exactly know what I would
do in some of the situations I've seen
you know read about on the New York
subway didn't that guy yeah do a thing
and now is he in jail did he get jailed
for it he's charged he's coming up for
trial this is uh I think his name Daniel
N I think former Marine uh there was a
guy on the subway who was um clearly off
his head on various drugs um was very
very violent towards people in the
carriage some point tore off his top and
like I'm going to kill you or something
like this and this Marine at that point
stepped in got him into a choke hoold
was clearly not meaning to do it but the
choke hold was too hard and he he
suffocated the guy and he died at the
scene and that man the xmarine is is is
charged with I think murder if not man I
think man slaughter
um and uh he could face a very
significant prison sentence there's a
lot of discussion in New York as to
whether or not a New York jury would
actually convict him where's he being
convicted in New York right um because
you could
say that the guy because there's a
racial element like with everything in
America uh and because the former Marine
was white and the guy off his head uh
was black there was an attempt of course
to put the the racial lens on it and
we'll see if a New York jury which will
be comprised half or so of women who
have been on the subway and have
probably had unpleasant
interactions uh will convict this man
for stepping in and genuinely think that
he meant to kill the guy or just this
was like a Good Samaritan act gone wrong
but it's there it's very solitary that
that sort of stuff there was a guy in
London about 15 years going very much
haunted me because the the fiance the
girlfriend did a victim impact statement
was particularly harrowing that they
were on the top of a bus in London and a
guy on the bus started throwing chips
like at people's heads and her fiance
got up to say look mate lay off and the
guy stabbed him he died and that's an
and and in the wake of a story like that
a lot more people in the society will be
Craven on the bus because they'll have
that EX example in their head my and my
fear about this case in the New York
Marine case is that he the marine by
doing what he did and it going wrong and
the publicity it got will stop other
people doing good St well 100% will have
done while it's pending whilst it's
pending yeah so lot rides off the
verdict that's a lot of pressure it's a
lot of pressure and in America with a
jury when you're on one of these cases
where Society could break out in rioting
I'm not sure it will for this guy
because the victim wasn't enormously um
upstanding as a member of the community
and had quite I don't think it was
videoed or at least they didn't see
video quite a lot of it was videoed but
he'd also had previous things where he
had like done a whole litany like a
laundry list of of times that he'd been
in arrested for yeah everything violent
conduct EXA so he won't be that
sympathetic a character but then there
are quite a lot of unsympathetic
characters who get dragged through the
the laundry of racial Justice stuff in
America and become Saints I won't name
any names but
going back to that sort of way you go
when you need more resilience thing and
The Bravery piece what was that CS Lewis
quote about about the times not being
optimal oh yeah what's that oh that's
one of my favorite um one of my favorite
sermons ever given was by CS Lewis
University Church in Oxford in October
1939 um yes I love that Lewis was a
master of Pros as well as theological
writing and he um he gave this beautiful
beautiful sermon in which he said yes he
said um you know the conditions are not
optimal at the moment uh the search for
truth and beauty that our species goes
through you know sort of going through
such a trial um but he says the point is
the conditions never were optimal they
never are it says even those periods of
History which which seem to be tranquil
like the 19th century turn out on closer
inspection to be filled with crises
alarms panics and all the rest of it he
says if if if if human if humankind had
put off the search for truth and Beauty
until the conditions were optimal the
search would never have
begun and the main point that he makes
is that um there is something wonderful
and unusual about human beings you know
he says the ants for instance have
chosen their own route they've chosen
the safety and the security of the hive
and presumably they have their
rewards but as he says he says men are
different and he gives beautiful list I
think I can remember it he
says they propound mathematical theorems
in baguer
cells they quote the latest poem whilst
advancing on the walls of Quebec make
jokes on scaffolds and comb their hair
at the gates of
theropo this is not panach he says it is
our
nature [__] that's cool is it's true as
well in my observation absolutely true
how so well because I've seen people in
baguer cities many times cities Under
Fire cities under bombardment cities
that are being raised to the ground and
um and human life goes
on it's an extraordinary
thing people continue their studies if
they can people continue their family
life if they
can they they've realized that the
condition conditions will never be
optimal I me they can be better and they
can be worse but they're never perfect
and I think that the real lesson of what
Lewis is saying is and I think it's an
important lesson for young people in our
time don't put off whatever it is you're
meant to do until the situation is
optimal don't don't fail to pursue what
it is you think you're meant to pursue
in your life
until you have total Tranquility for
instance you know that you have the
house or the apartment you would like
until you have the relationship you
would like until you you have the don't
put it off until
then or until the world is
peaceful which will never
happen never happen never has happen
never will
happen don't put it off till then
because if you put it off till then it
means you'll put it off
forever so do whatever you're meant to
be doing now start now if you haven't
started already and if you started
already don't go any
slower for God's sake and and this is
part of the you know the the cost of our
times I've said this before but part of
the cost of our times is the enormous
expense of energy on idiotic things that
you can do nothing about I think we
should say to more people don't Howl at
the
Moon don't shake your fists at the
skies get on with what you're meant to
be
doing and that'll be different for
everybody but I just I'm very um
um
uh well I'm too irritable
to put up with going at the slow speed
that a lot of people want to make us all
go out these days so
I want them out of my way yeah I think a
lot about the arisal of victimhood
culture yeah got no time for yeah it
seems to me that like an existential
crisis is actually a luxurious position
to be in because the bottom levels of M
hierarchy of needs have been sorted and
victimhood culture is so rampant at the
moment because the human
systems demand for challenge is
outstripping reality's ability to
deliver it to
it all of the problems most of the
problems that previously would have
captured the front of our attention have
been moved out of the way yeah
absolutely I mean our sensitivity to
challenge is now being tuned up yeah
hunger and so on yeah yeah
[Music]
um I think that's true by the way I'm
just amazed by that I mean I feel
sometimes or increasingly like I'm just
from a different world than the one
we're now in um suddenly a different
Society I'm sure it was the same with
you when you were growing up but the
Britain iin was um a place which which
liked
resilience I mean we admired
resilience we didn't admire people who
whined and
muled in fact those are the people you
avoided yeah at all
costs gosh he's a wher god he's a whiner
I mean you know and people said things
like you know mustn't Grumble it's one
of my favorites how are you mustn't
Grumble now i''d say well actually I've
got stage four
cancer not sure that's grumbling I know
but we talked about it like that people
from that generation still say thing I
have a friend of that generation who's
got cancer at the moment and she she's
like oh it's so boring
it's so
boring everyone I grew up with was like
that now you might say there's something
unhealthy about that but there's
actually something healthy about it
too um and there's something healthy
about assuming that everyone has their
troubles and so they don't need you to
add yours to their list of things to
worry about that day and you know cheer
people up and encourage them where you
can and so on so they don't bring them
down well it's the it's the weird sort
of self-fulfilling prophecy of
pedestalize victimhood that there is a
limitless sky on how much victimhood you
can claim yes whereas if your status and
your prestige is Downstream from your
accomplishments there is a limit on how
much you can accomplish because you need
to go out and [__] do it yes right
reality is going to constrain how much
impressive stuff you can go and do but
there is a
a ineffable Universe of I athletes foot
and my my gluten intolerance and my
chronic flatulence and my you know
whatever else yes um those are things
that you can just continue to accumulate
like trinkets yes I just find those
people boring uh I just don't care for
victimhood I think it's an undesirable
emotion it's it's it's a sign of a
rather undesirable
person um I but I don't know why we've
given into this this I just I'm
genuinely particularly in Britain I'm
just baffled by it because it wasn't the
country we had well maybe it's you know
how you said your solution for courage
was to surround yourself with courageous
people if you kind of get this mimetic
wave yes almost moving through where
fewer courageous people are around which
creates fewer courageous Role Models
which means to you know yeah yeah yeah
and you have the thing of men being
persuaded to become cringing Unix it's
not a good thing well that's another
reason why you know
this conversation around the guy in the
subway is so interesting
because is
he is he really supposed to stand up for
the women or is that is he mansplaining
what if he
mansplains while he stops a woman
dragged around by her hair well of
course the answer to that is the era has
to say you know what there's no such
thing as man explaining or at least it's
not very important um get onto something
more important like women not being
assaulted on the subway you know choose
choose choose your priorities well the
denial of sex differences would lead to
the conclusion that that woman can why
should the woman why shouldn't the women
stand up why shouldn't they use their
upper body weight yes yeah to push this
fentanyl fuel Maniac off this lady well
I say it's a luxury belief that one and
doesn't meet reality very well I'm not
sure anyone would be very happy if the
men in the carriage said to the woman
women in the carriage go on go on your
turn yeah we've had are centuries of
patriarchal hierarchy and warfare what
is it there's one that got my goat
recently with um somebody was in the US
or UK it always happens now when
everything anything comes up about
conflict Hillary Clinton was one of the
worst culprits at doing this but they
they say they always say this thing of
one of the reasons you've got to stop
any War once it starts is they say you
know the first victims of war are women
why they [__] not the men they're men
who do most of the fighting and the
dying Hillary Clinton's quite well then
the W they're widows and
then ah yeah the the the poor widows of
the men that are dead yeah there's a
actually the British mod has a thing of
has a special um section now dedicated I
think thanks to the impressive Insight
of that military expert Angelina Jolie
uh they have um a um special bit of the
mod dedicated to women in conf the
suffering of women in Conflict why not
have a the suffering of Men In conflict
as
well such weird priorities our age it's
totally unserious this age is so
unserious it's why you can't help
thinking that at some point The Maniacs
the The Barbarians will just break in
because we've made ourselves so
weak but it's so captivating right this
is what I meant when I said you know
have we progressed beyond Peak woke
because it seems to me like both the
hyper woke and Hyper anti-woke thing is
capturing so much of the attention oh
they're just I'm so bored of these
people they're so ridiculous can't spend
any more of my life life listening to
them I don't want to listen to the
slowest kid in the class I don't want to
go at his or her speed I don't want to
talk to somebody so mentally impaired
that they think that we are a weirdly
hrodi species or that you can that the
clownfish is a useful species to
interpret behavior of human beings we
can't go at this speed
no
no 20 years ago at the dawn of the
internet age we had hoped that we would
get so much farther in the 21st century
and here we are with this stupid Society
slowed down by Maniacs debating the
first thing we knew boy or
girl like no not going at that speed
Emma
ranu did an advert for HSBC recently
which you may have missed HSBC rewrote
three classic fairy tales uh their book
is called fairer tales and it shows that
women don't need men at all with
financial attitudes shaped as early as 5
years old the new book challenges
traditional gender stereotypes the new
book called fairy tales princesses doing
it for themselves reimagines Cinderella
Sleeping Beauty and Rapunzel as
successful business women Prince
Charming successful business women
Prince Charming is a race is the main
character uh Emma ranu read to them so
in the end the princesses didn't need a
prince to save them they set up their
own businesses saved their money and
then spent it very wisely maybe one day
you'll buy a tower or set up your own
shoe business that's a quote said the
tennis player that's the worst I mean I
read Megan markle's book The
Bench and that's
worse that's
worse um
wow yeah um what an inspiring tale
fairer Tales um it's so princesses doing
it for themselves have you seen the um
the uh the the South Park episode of
where um uh Cartman wakes up he has a a
nightmare you told me about this lunch
yesterday for the people that haven't
seen it what is kman um kartman has has
a nightmare it turns out he's he is a
diverse black woman his character is
recast and all of his friends Kenny and
everyone else are diverse female or
transracial characters and then Carman
wakes up from the night no and his
mother comes in what is it what is it
are you having another dream where once
again all my all my favorite characters
in in the cartoons have been replaced by
ethnically diverse women and and she
goes it's okay C it's okay uh the the
CEO of Disney isn't hiding under your
bed would you check would you check
would you check Mom okay I checked she's
not there I'm worried she's going to
come out again replace all my favorite
characters with ethnically diverse
women I love those guys God they keep
doing it um yeah I mean it's the same
thing with there was that rather
unappealing um young woman who uh was
meant to be play is playing Snow White
in the new Disney no white Rachel Zigler
no no no somebody else and she it is is
it yeah Rachel Ziggler Zigler well she
said uh Prince Charming wasn't a prince
he was a stalker yeah and uh she didn't
need a prince charming to discover that
she could be the woman she could be I
mean this is like sub Barack Obama Circa
2007 like the princess is the person
she's been waiting for or something you
your sister's keeper I I
I why don't they invent new tale that's
what I can never understand with that
why don't they just invent new Tales
instead of screwing up every existing
tale that's love make your boring movie
about an inspirational tale of a woman
who want to start a business and then
does and has some success I mean okay
make that into a film why do you have to
go and rans Sack and rape all of pillage
all of the the storehouse of stories
that people liked Bret Cooper's playing
Snow White for daily wi did you see that
announcement what you hav seen this let
me tell you Jeremy boring and Ben
Shapiro are doing their own liveaction
remake of Snow White with Brett
Cooper as Snow White because she's like
West End trained right so she's a very
well- trained supposedly a very well-
trained actor who can sing apparently
it's like the triple threat podcast act
thing right uh and they announced it the
other week it's going to be coming out
next year God I hope they slay Disney
there's a rumor that Disney has had to
re-shoot a ton of scenes including all
of the dwarf scenes because originally
the dwarves weren't dwarves they were
like a an multi-racial just group of
different people they were diverse
ethnic women it was the sou thing again
uh but
apparently they this is just a rumor but
apparently they've reshot it all of the
scenes with the dwarfs to CGI actual
dwarfs in oh so they've gone full yeah
because I know that there was a there
was a Revolt of the dwarves which is
something you don't hear every day no
there was a Revolt of the dwarfs because
of course dwarf actors who have their
Equity cards are annoyed because there's
not many dead jobs yeah You' have
presumed that there should have at least
been seven yeah AB plus a stunt actor
stunt dwarf stunt one to do all seven
stunts well you could have 14 I guess it
depends how how demanding the ACT how
much you want to spread around the dwarf
actor Community yeah the point is is is
is there actually was apparently
Rebellion about this because these are
some of the few like dead roles we've
got well is this not the same the people
who didn't cast that is that not the
same group of people that would say we
can only have a gay actor playing a gay
man and we can only have a black actor
playing a black man and we can only have
those people are such I won't use the
word uh yeah I mean that again we
haven't got time to go the pace of these
people acting is pretending to be other
people people will be shocked that most
people who play Hamlet are not
themselves members of the Danish royal
family welcome to the world of make Bel
a charity shop in Swansea asked people
not to donate sex toys uh barnardo's
customers have been asked to refrain
from donating used and unused marital
aids as they aren't quite the sort of
toys we're looking
for when they say we want like but your
old book old toys they didn't mean sex
sex toys right I think that's a
perfectly good policy for a secondhand
shop customers were rifling through the
secondhand dildo
Vin you don't
what have they got in
here is there a dressing room yeah I uh
customers were also reminded that the
branch had CCTV so that these items can
be traced back to the original owners oh
oh according to that means that means
that you there's like a um
a what's it called that thing in
Australia the boomerang that's the
boomerang effect give your dildo away
then it's back on your doorstep the next
morning God damn it why can I get rid of
this thing Over the Hedge but he keeps
Landing in Bard and then they bring it
back it's a dildo that will never die
yeah yeah thinking about well thank you
for that story that was beautiful well
I've got another one is there is there a
lesson we can take from this oh I think
just be careful where you put your
dildos really is the matter there's the
moral of the story yeah yeah never leave
your dildo in bernardos yeah definitely
not in the Bargain Bin uh School in
Lafayette has refused to celebrate
Halloween because it isn't inclusive
while going all out for LGBT plus
history month is there much history with
LGBT plus there's gay history I mean
there lots of gay people in history and
there is that but it's also what we used
to call
history um uh there isn't much tea
history um there's uh B history I mean
there are sort of I'm a bit skeptical
about bisexuality but um um there's a
bit of bisexuality in history of course
um but I mean again these people are
such ignores they never know anything I
can't tell you Chris I mean I have to
deal with some of this [__]
and they just don't know anything and
they keep Rec it's like the Orwell thing
they keep reporting their So-Cal
discoveries as if people didn't know
them before and everybody knew most of
the stuff that they are trying to bring
out and it's just very tedious and again
what's happened to the mainstream thing
of it why aren't we concentrating on big
subjects big authors big historical
issues instead of this boring slow
pace we're here at ARC and we're going
to be attending at some point this
week I can't remember what the tagline
is something about a better F vision for
the future a more positive vision for
the future I think yeah better story
better story for the future sorry Jordan
and
um what is your or H How would how do
you you think that we can begin to tell
a more positive story for the future
because it seems to me that much of the
proposals are quite easily criticized
and often rightly so but does this sort
of zero Su view of happiness and growth
that somebody else's happiness somehow
detracts from mine well that's a
particularly British view of course very
much yeah yeah yeah yeah if that guy's
got something it's cuz I've not got it
Tak it from me Tak it from me uh yeah
but what's a more positive vision of the
future
well one would be that we're not facing
imminent apocalypse and catastrophe uh
all the time from every possible
Direction and particularly not ones that
people have whipped up a new generation
into a further over I mean I think that
the green apocalyptic thing is
particularly damaging to young people I
think it's very very bad for their
mental health very had very very
detrimental to their sense of how they
build a future and I think a lot of
young people have been lied to about the
proximity
of uh Global Climate catastrophe I mean
every time there isn't an actual
catastrophe going on in the world uh our
leaders go straight back to the climate
catastrophy or the climate crisis they
now call
it what is happening is not a
crisis um it may be a problem to be
managed but you there's a luxury in
calling such things a crisis a crisis is
like know my shoes are on
fire that's a crisis not
like it's possible that in 40
years we'll need more AC I don't see
that as a
crisis um but so yes and but I I think
that in general there are several things
that are big stories big narratives AIT
people are being spun which are
incredibly um innovating that is they
they sap energy out of the society you
could feel it the hopelessness if you
tell young people they're not going to
live into adulthood because they're all
going to burn to death uh the
hopelessness of saying you know you you
you you can't change anything or that
this is the trajectory we're on I think
that one of the other ones in the green
stuff is the hopelessness of saying to
people effectively you shouldn't um
leave any footprint on the planet
including children including
children
um and just to put one thing out there
about the the hopelessness of that I
mean the there's this new thing that
many cities have signed up to including
London
uh which which is a future in which
among other things we will not be
allowed to move around very much and we
will be allowed a flight perhaps every
six years I think it is what's this it's
this City's what's it called I'm
blanking on the name it's this new
proposal for cities in 2030 or something
sadique Khan has signed up London to it
is it one of these carbon neutral
fantasies no fun 2030 yeah and and one
of them is that you won't be allowed to
fly more than once every X number of
years and of course none of it makes any
sense because among other things all
that means is part from the fact the
airline industry is destroyed is the
what it means is the cost of an airline
ticket will be like 40 times
higher um but so they always assume you
can do all of these things and nothing
will change you know amazingly you'll be
able to put a rule like that in and you
won't destroy the airline industry or
whatever but all of it is just so
antihuman I mean it is so anti-human
like the the aspiration of human beings
should not be to be born fight against
the patriarchy leave no carbon footprint
and die in the most
ethically fine
manner preferably taken out at a Swiss
Clinic you know and then like burnt in a
cardboard box it's not a very heroic
narrative you
know and I think that actually we do
Orient our lives around stories and
around narratives
and we should not have the unic
narrative that I've just laid out we
should have heroic narratives I mean for
instance you know The Narrative of the
um of Adventure of life being an
adventure that you set out on a path and
hope you know hopefully you set yourself
out on a heroic path or at least an
exciting path you know I mean the
Counterpoint of the one I laid out
earlier of the one you know you don't
know you know sorry the the counterpart
of the one I laid out earlier which is
the you know everything that's going to
happen if you go along this path of
things other people have persuaded you
to say MH is well you know where you're
going you know everything to say and you
know kind of what trajectory your life
will be
on well you know I say well yeah and
there's another trajectory as well and
it's the one that I and I suspect you
Orient ourselves in our life which is I
don't know
exactly I don't know with that certainty
I don't know what'll happen but if I put
one foot fairly sh footedly in front of
the
next and and tread
well
and Orient Myself by things like
truth sure I don't have the
certainty but it's an adventure and it's
my adventure your adventure you actually
own it and then see that you'll actually
have your life you can feel proud of
what you got to right because you
weren't being ventriloquized by somebody
else's you didn't spend your life saying
things you don't know or mean or believe
or just a repeating like a
parrot um in order to keep in with a
group of people you shouldn't seek the
affirmation from you you you will live
your life remember that the outcomes
that most people get are ones that you
don't want in any case the average
American is obese divorced and with less
than 1K in the bank
so sobering isn't it doing what
everybody else does sounds like a very
Surefire strategy but the outcomes are
ones that you don't want yeah well I
mean look and that can be the case with
with financially successful people I
mean it can be the case with people I
mean I often say that people who go into
professions which they don't like and
and again it's it's interesting I mean
some of them are there are ones that
people apologize for as you talk to them
notice that there certain um normally
these days one of the biggest
self-deprecating professions is lawyers
you say to somebody what are you doing
I'm a
lawyer I think why that yeah you spent
five years in full-time education three
years in developing to and normally it's
like they think oh well it's not very
interesting or something but I think why
wouldn't you do something where you I am
a lawyer it's fantastic I love doing
this that's British lawyers again for
you I bet well know I've seen Americans
do that as well my point is is it is and
they're financially well rewarded yeah
um you know and there's there's rules
you can follow on that like um like
there are ones I don't understand if you
are doing a job that pays you well and
allows you to provide for your loved
ones that's worth doing if even if it's
not your optimal
role um doing a role that you don't much
care for and you're not providing for
other
people and you don't see any particular
purposes like that's probably not a good
idea or you could go you know that there
are other options and other routes open
to you that would allow you to also
provide for the family you're providing
for yeah yeah The Bravery narrative is
definitely one that I think is
lacking and this risk aversion that we
have this young people getting their
driver's licenses later than ever most
common living arrangement for men under
the age of 35 is still living at home
with their parents yeah it's just such
such an awful stat people going in into
full-time employment later than ever I
think about you know when we were
actually no you are the worst person to
talk about this you told me you didn't
get your driver's license until some
ungodly but most people but I'm not risk
ofers just lazy on that they manifest
similarly uh most people C 17 years old
in the UK driver's license I want to be
free I want to be liberated I don't want
to have to be asking mom and dad for
lifts etc etc and
uh yeah there's not a there's not a
Narrative of Adventure no and I think
that is important because I think that
you if you don't have a narrative of
Adventure and success and an idea of
what that looks like um you know you are
disproportionately likely to to live a
more miserable life
um and I think probably both of us to
some extent have worked our way out as
we've done it and you know tro in a path
is not completely clear and if you said
to me what are you going to do in 10
years Time dress I couldn't particularly
tell you i' tell you roughly what I'd
like to do but it's not entirely clear
yeah it might be if I was in a corporate
law firm and hoping to make partner or
something like that but yeah I mean the
the um lack of clarity on it is should
be energizing I'd have thought well
that's what's exciting about it for also
for the desire for certainty which is
also exactly where the conspiracism
comes from from right because it it
removes random chance from the world and
makes everything coordinated rather than
coincidental that desire for
certainty really dissuades people from
going and doing something which has
potentially outsized outcomes well look
at look at what happens The Narrative of
leaving home or leaving the village or
leaving the
town um there's every
reason not to go because if you
go you risk a lot of things one of them
is
failing and if you
go and you
fail then you have to go back to where
you were from a failure with your tail
between your legs and then you can
console yourself that you tried it but
it didn't work a lot of people will not
even make the try because they think it
won't work
so they never
leave and other people go and they
finally make it to the city and I mean
that's this is a story as old as our
species they finally make it to the city
or large Gathering Place and they they
make they make it there you know one of
the reasons why New York is a thrilling
city is it's filled with people making
it you know I mean plenty of people who
will fail uh and it's it's very harsh in
a way because the the two are so close
together you know the millionaires
blocks will have a a veteran with a sign
lying on the street
outside so you always and and then you
get that simultaneous thing of success
and the and the mirror of it
of desperate failure or I don't mean
that a judgmental way in the case of the
veteran but desperate life yep very
close to each other and I suspect that
both of these things are f up New
Yorkers all the time yeah well you're
getting to see how far you could go and
how far you could fall shown in front of
you all the time yes yeah there's a an
interesting study by Candice Blake in
Australia that looked at uh wealth and
equality and local ecologies
positively
predicting
uh self uh sexualization of women in
online dating profiles so okay I think I
followed that yeah if uh there is high
wealth inequality women both see the
sort of partner they could get in their
wildest dreams and in their worst
nightmares and it positively predicts uh
more sexualized images in online dating
profiles and social media and her
argument was that
it amps up a woman's
um Competitive Edge in terms of finding
a partner that they think would be able
to ensure they don't end
up down at the bottom end of the
inequality distribution and instead they
end up in the clouds where they've seen
people's outcomes
occurring well of course there are also
people who fake it
so I mean um well that's the effective
way to play the game I was once in India
and uh had a a guide who I got talking
to and I said um I said we're talking
about how easy or otherwise dating was
in the outskirts of Delhi which means
the slams and he said the trick is um he
did describe it as a trick is you if you
meet a girl you like you you go for date
with her but you borrow your friend's
shoes for instance there'll be a friend
who has a pair of trainers sneakers that
that are nice good and you borrow his
shoes for the date and then like another
time you might borrow a friend's
motorbike so like the pool of men helps
like swap around right okay and the idea
is they have one good dating outfit and
vehicle between 10 people he said the
idea was that you get the woman to say
she loves you and she'll marry you and
then you do the reveal that with
somebody else's shoes your [__] shoes
yeah which I thought was
both
horrific admirable he told it to me like
that and horribly uh
recognizable um think of all the people
who Splash around money in restaurants
and things who don't really have it at
all pretend to live above their means or
do live above their means it's all to
try to ENT trap a me
I think people do a lot for sex yeah I
know I've seen Douglas Murray ladies and
gentlemen Douglas I really appreciate
you what what's coming up next what can
people expect over the next few months
uh I don't know I don't know what I
expect over the next few months I'm
going to a couple of War zones and we'll
report back I appreciate you thank you
mate thank you thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
with Douglas you will love my fulllength
over 2hour long podcast with Jordan
Peterson
go
on give it a tap